Let's go next to our caller from the six zero
nine area code.
Who's calling today from six zero nine.
Hey, David, this is Boaz from New Jersey.
Hey Boaz, what's up?
Uh, so I just wanted to, uh, ask you a question.
How long do you think it's going to take and,
or what is it going to take to completely
flip the democratic party to be a better representative
or a middle working class people?
Um, we elected AOC, um, representative Ilhan
Omar.
Um, and let's say we elected Bernie Sanders.
Um, and let's say this are two terms.
Um, which would be great.
What is it going to take to create a progressive
party and make that the democratic party?
What do you think?
Well, what you have to understand is that
if it were just a matter of the country being
more progressive, we would have had a far
more progressive democratic party years ago.
And that's where you have to integrate into
the analysis, the effect of money in politics
and the disproportionate outsized influence
of big corporations and money in politics.
Because the population has been well to the
left of the democratic party for a long time.
When you poll people about healthcare, when
you pull people about, uh, abortion, gay marriage,
the war on drugs, drug legalization, even
on money in politics itself, the American
public is well to the left of where our elected
officials are.
And so what you have to then understand is
that even though the democratic party is certainly
to the left of the Republican party, because
the same corporate influences are affecting
both parties to similar degrees, that is really
what is holding back the democratic party
is simply moving to the left.
There.
There's a whole bunch of different reforms.
There's no doubt that if Bernie were to have
eight years and the house continues moving
more to the left and democratic senators are
replaced with more progressive democratic
senators, of course that's going to move the
democratic party to the left.
But to really break the status quo, you've
got to fix campaign finance.
You've got to potentially put in place term
limits, which are also a factor, uh, that
that prevents, um, our elected officials from
just doing what the people want rather than
figuring out, well, what are corporate interests
going to do when I'm up for reelection if
I do this or I do that.
So there's a whole bunch of systemic change
that needs to happen in addition to continuing
to elect people that are further to the left.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
All right, Boaz from New Jersey.
Great to hear from you.